now it's joe biden the radical left get
ready to raise taxes and the price of
everything that you buy their efforts
apparently know no boundaries in fact
treasury secretary janet yellen is now
proposing a global minimum corporate
income
tax which of course will only be passed
on to you the american people
by the administration no longer even
trying to hide that these tax hikes are
going to hurt the middle class
over even fake news cnn energy secretary
granholm
asked about a wall street journal
article that says that taxes will quote
hit the middle class hard take a look
the tax code's not fair and so what joe
biden wants to do is to say corporations
should pay their fair share
in the same way that a plumber and a
teacher
would have to pay 22 percent of their
income or 24 percent of their income
corporations should have to pay their
fair share too
she didn't deny the taxes will hurt the
middle class heroes reaction texas
senator ted cruz was still monitoring
that car chase in california as well
senator um corporations
don't pay taxes i argue or very little
what they will do is they will
increase the cost of the product or
services that they have
just like energy prices are going up
because of biden's policies
that's another tax on the american
people thoughts
well you know i'm reminded of what
hillary clinton said a few years ago she
said don't let anybody tell you a
corporation or a business will give you
a job
well these are folks that don't
understand how the economy works
you know you know what the people of
texas want we want jobs we want more
jobs
and how do you get jobs you create an
environment where small businesses can
grow and expand and hire people
we've just come out of a year-long
pandemic that has hammered
small businesses all across the country
and what a joe biden
and and his leftist cronies in the
cabinet want to do
every one of them wants to raise your
taxes they want to jack up the taxes
on american families they want to jack
up the taxes on every small business in
america
at the exact time that millions of small
businesses
are are hanging on by a thread they're
right at the edge between going bankrupt
and surviving and what the byte
administration is doing
is giving a shove you know the early
projections are this biden
tax increase the biggest tax increase in
a generation
is expected to almost immediately cost a
hundred and fifty thousand jobs and
potentially a lot more after that
hey senator it's it's the biggest tax
increase in 30 years now
janet yellen wants a global minimum tax
rate
uh now we see people leaving california
new york new jersey illinois
they're going to states like yours in
texas or ron de santos state
in florida and the carolinas
now if they have a global corporate
minimum taxes and the idea well
corporations leave big cities for tax
friendlier states like texas
they might start thinking about leaving
the united states
and isn't that what that's about
look big government socialists want to
tax everybody
all the time they're looking for
mechanisms to keep raising money why
because they think they can spend your
money better than you can that they have
all these big ideas
you look at joe biden's supposed
infrastructure uh bill
over two trillion dollars do you know
how much of that infrastructure goes
to building roads and bridges five
percent
95 of his infrastructure bill
is spending money on things other than
roads and bridges this is a shell game
and the shell game it always ends with
the same trick
your taxes go up on your wages on your
small business on your employer
and the big government socialist takes
the money and they spend it on the
big new green new deal they spend it on
their own
their own special interest projects look
i'm a big believer when our economy has
taken a hard hit
that the american people the working men
and women deserve to keep more of their
paycheck in their own pockets
you know we had prior to this pandemic
we
had the lowest unemployment in 50 years
it was incredible
the economic boom we had and that came
from low taxes and low regulations what
does joe biden want to do
high taxes high regulations that's
destroying
your job it's bad for the country and
and it is we're going to see a whole lot
more of that over the next two years
unfortunately and
i doubt that texas the state of texas is
going to get a refund
for all that's going on at the border
down there
and the burden that that's that your
state now has to take on senator thank
you